- This is what your hair
looks like when it's dirty.
- [Narrator] And this is what
shampoo does to that dirt.
- Surfactants form these
micelles around the dirt,
which is what grabs onto dirt and oil.
It's like, no, no, I don't wanna go.
That was the dirt.
It's screaming for its life. (laughs)
- [Narrator] Erica Douglas
has been a cosmetic chemist
for more than a decade,
and today she's going to
break down the ingredients
in Head & Shoulders Classic
Clean dandruff shampoo.
- It's about to get messy. (laughs)
It's actually a fairly simple formula.
Not a lot of ingredients.
That means that there's not a
lot of fluff in this formula.
- [Narrator] Erica broke
down the ingredients
into these categories.
Let's start here.
- One of the first ingredients that I see
is pyrithione zinc.
This is one of the most common actives
used in the cosmetic
space to fight dandruff.
Without this ingredient,
it's just the shampoo.
Dandruff is actually caused by a fungus
called Malassezia, and
it feeds on the oil.
- [Narrator] The FDA allows
up to 2% of pyrithione zinc
in products like this shampoo,
which are applied and then rinsed off.
The Classic Clean formula
uses pyrithione zinc at 1%.
But in the EU.
- They actually banned pyrithione zinc
mutagenic, or toxic for reproduction.
According to the company,
the EU version uses this ingredient
instead of pyrithione zinc.
So the active ingredient
handles the dandruff,
but surfactants like these sulfates
are what actually clean the scalp.
- Surfactants are the
soapy part of the shampoo.
It's what causes the suds,
it's actually what is pulling
the dirt and the oil off
of your hair and scalp.
I believe that they are using this
as their primary surfactant,
and the cocamidopropyl betaine
is the secondary
surfactant in this formula.
- [Narrator] Surfactants work
a little something like this.
- We're gonna just use
some regular pepper,
have it float on top of
some normal deionized water.
These surfactants have
their hydrophilic head
and their hydrophobic tails,
and so they form these micelles
around the dirt, which is
what grabs onto dirt and oil,
and helps it to remove it
from the hair and the scalp.
Instantly you see how it repels it.
It's like running from the shampoo.
- [Narrator] Some surfactants create
more suds than others, but.
- Foam actually doesn't dictate
how well a shampoo is cleaning your hair.
There are certain surfactants
that can produce a lot
of foam like this one,
but then there are other
surfactants that are more mild.
Does not mean that it's not working.
So foam is kind of like for aesthetics.
And we call this the
cylinder shake method.
You can see how much
foam is going to last,
and how it separates out.
A lot of hairstylists view
sulfates as being too harsh.
I see sulfates as a great surfactant
when used in moderation, and
they're also being formulated
in conjunction with
other conditioning agents
that allow it to moisturize
and condition the hair
at the same time.
- [Narrator] That's the job
of this ingredient here,
otherwise known as a silicone.
- They help to maintain the
water level in your hair.
This is water with just a
little bit of Violet 1 colorant,
versus when I do the same
thing with dimethicone.
And dimethicone just has a little bit
of the Blue 1 colorant.
You notice how the water went
right through the sponge.
That's because it soaked in
and went straight to the bottom,
versus this silicone stain right on top.
This is the difference between
when your hair is absorbing moisture,
versus using a silicone like dimethicone
to help seal the cuticle and
maintain moisture content.
Silicones have really gotten this bad rep.
They've been thought
to weigh the hair down
or leave a buildup.
This is absolutely not true.
They have the ability to stay on the hair,
to seal the cuticles, and
they do come off the hair
when using a shampoo.
- [Narrator] Now, for
what gives the shampoo
it's distinct look.
- So Head & Shoulders
uses Blue 1 and Red 33
as their colorants, and that's how you get
this really cool light blue looking color.
In addition to the glycol distearate,
which is used as a pearlizing agent
to give it that pearl look.
I don't know what the
ratios are that they use.
That's their proprietary information.
First, I'm gonna start
with my blue number one.
Ooh, okay, and then we'll
try to see what happens
when we add a little Red 33.
As you can see, I literally
put less than a gram in,
and that's how dark it got.
- [Narrator] Blue 1 and Red
33 are both synthetic colors
approved for use in cosmetics
with some use restrictions.
- Some of the concerns that
come around synthetic colors
would be that it could
potentially be an irritant
or an allergen for some people.
- [Narrator] According to the
environmental working group,
Safety Ratings, Blue 1
is marked as high hazard
while Red 33 is marked as moderate.
A Head & Shoulders
representative reiterated
that these dyes are FDA approved,
noting that the Classic Clean formula
is known for its signature blue color.
And when it comes to fragrance.
- It just lists that they use fragrance.
Nothing else.
Fragrance contains 30,
40 ingredients sometimes.
The ingredients that make up a fragrance
are often proprietary.
- [Narrator] But according to
Erica's scientific sniffer.
- Product has floral
and aquatic notes.
- [Narrator] While it's
not listed on the label,
Head & Shoulders does
list over 20 ingredients
found in the Classic Clean
fragrance formulation online,
including some considered
allergens in the EU.
And soon, this could become
a more common practice.
- A new law was put into action
which actually will now
require cosmetic products
to list fragrance allergens
on the label going into 2024.
- [Narrator] Consistency
is also a crucial part
of a shampoo's formulation.
- Some of the ingredients
that they're using
to give that thick, creamy
feel is glycol distearate,
also the guar hydroxypropyl
trimonium chloride.
Guar is a great conditioning
detangling agent,
but it also gives the
formula some thickness.
With salt can give you that thick feel.
- [Narrator] And while the
final product feels thick.
- The most surprising thing
about shampoo formulations
is that it's mostly water.
Any product that has water
in it has the potential
to grow mold, fungus, bacteria.
Ugh, we don't want any of that stuff.
- [Narrator] Different packages
The Wall Street Journal purchased
had different preservatives listed.
- The preservative used in this
product is sodium benzoate.
- [Narrator] Another
version of the same product
lists these two additional preservatives,
which have a high incidence
with skin allergies.
The company said it recently shifted away
from this preservative combination
to one with sodium benzoate.
But products with the combination
are still currently sold on store shelves.
Before a product hits the shelf,
one crucial element must be tested.
That's the pH.
- We are measuring a pH of 7.3
for this Head & Shoulders product.
This is not abnormal,
but it is on the high end
of what I would normally see.
- [Narrator] Head & Shoulders
said this reading is in line
with the standard range of its formulas,
which it said remains America's
number one anti-dandruff shampoo
with moisture levels as they are.
And there are few things to
note on the overall packaging.
- They claim that this
bottle is paraben free.
I would agree that this
is a paraben free product.
The paraben issue is a
very provocative topic.
There have been some
preliminary studies that show
that there could be possible linkage
between parabens and cancer.
There's no conclusive scientific data
that links paraben usage and
cosmetics directly to cancer,
but the possibilities
of it being a carcinogen
has provoked some limitations
on how this ingredient
is being used in the cosmetic space.
- [Narrator] And Erica sees
some opportunities for improvements.
- If I could change
anything about this formula,
I would probably add a few more
conditioning and moisturizing agents
just to give more functionality
and more control to the actual hair.
I think that dandruff
is a little hush hush
because nobody wants to
be known as the snowflake.
I think a lot of people associate dandruff
with being unclean, but
that's completely not true.
We need to talk more about it.
(upbeat bright music)